[Music]
this
event is different from all previous
years
we can reach out to many many more
people and it has opened up
new opportunities
[Music]
we did also focus in a different way
on the actual content so that we made
sure that
the message
[Music]
as far as the preparations are concerned
they were
they were quite daunting catholic
personnel
it is
we had several teams working together
that had not
previously worked together so that was
also a big adventure
but i think in the end it all came
together quite well
[Music]
the european day of languages started as
a grassroots event
it has actually grown exponentially over
the 20 years since it was first launched
once a year
we really celebrate every aspect
of multilingualism and language learning
and it's very nice to see
how this community is now alive among
language teachers
and also among learners the combined
efforts the synergies
between everything that is going on here
there and everywhere
makes really a tremendously strong
impact and force
[Music]
you